[Aplausos]
[Música]
furia y tristeza en ereván
cientos de personas protestaron contra
el acuerdo de paz con azerbaiyán el
mismo que en bakú ven como un triunfo y
que en armenia sabe a derrota
la multitud cantan nicole el traidor
refiriéndose al primer ministro ni culpa
xinjiang quien firmó el acuerdo mientras
un miembro del partido opositor armenia
prospera alienta a la multitud esto a
pesar de que las reuniones públicas
están prohibidas por ley marcial de modo
que varios manifestantes fueron
arrestados
el acuerdo por el que protestan
establece que azerbaiyán se quedará con
las áreas de las que se apoderó en las
últimas seis semanas de enfrentamientos
incluyendo sushi o sucia dependiendo de
quién la llave esta es una ciudad
estratégica no muy lejos de la capital
de la región estepa naker y sobre la
línea que conecta al territorio en
disputa con armenia ahora a armenia se
tiene que retirar de las zonas de
alrededor pero algunos creen que de no
haber cedido armenia podría haber
perdido mucho más si la confrontación
seguía ese ritmo íbamos a perder todo
nagorno karabaj trabajo nunca
y por si nunca buscar sage
y tendríamos muchos más muertos
el acuerdo de paz llega después de
múltiples ceses al fuego fallidos y tras
un millar de muertos